голосування
це питання переносити ви знаєте що це
вже тоді просто повне обличчя слухи які
заради бізнесових питань про енергоатом
Да готові поступатися насправді
принциповим для України сьогодні
медведчука Рабінович і цілоїнецький іншу
депутатів
так
кузьмінал Аксьонова тих людей які є
громадянами України і деркача тобто всіх
тих хто порушували справи проти Росії
Вони залишаються депутатами Верховної
Ради вони відмовляються ставити на
голосування закон про заборону
російської церкви буде відмовляються
ставити на голосування закон про
деколонізацію
і технічна культура Розказує що
європейська солідарка закону там щось
там е-е про проти в боротьби
постанова Олексійович Давайте ви
боротьбу з елементами ви хочете
перетворити на обстеження за кожним
громадянином України цинічна тварина
хоче
те як зараз відбувається нарада голови
Верховної Ради щодо наступного питання
що ми вимагаємо щоби було першим
питанням поставлено питання про
припинення депутатських повноважень
п'ятої колони медведчука деркача і інше
замість того Влада хоче це питання
затягнути придумали закони сьогодні
право головне завдання не винести
значить це питання на розгляд Ми
добиваємось з того прямо зараз на Ваших
очах друзі щоби нарешті ця п'ята колона
ми вже перемогли друзі буде зараз
розгляд буде зараз розгляд питання це
дуже важливо ми не дамо гратися в ті
ігри п'ятий колонії копняка підзад з
Верховної Ради від України
вже готові нас тут хороша компанія
друзі отак і боремося